One of the really useful things to
understand,
and this took me a long time to
formulate properly.
You know,
you hear the terror management
theorists,
for example,
and they have this idea that you're,
you're meaning representation.
The story you tell about the world
regulates your,
your death anxiety.
It's something like that.
But that's not right.
I mean,
it's close to right,
and it's a smart idea.
It came from Ernest Becker,
by the way,
who wrote a book called the denial of
death,
which is actually quite a good book,
even though it's wrong.
You know,
sometimes a book can be very useful.
It can be usefully wrong in that.
And Becker's book is usefully wrong
because he thought that it's the
internal representation of your belief
system that regulates your anxiety.
And that anxiety is fundamentally in the
final analysis anxiety about death.
It's like,
well,
okay,
fine.
It's a reasonable proposition,
but that isn't how it works.
You see,
it isn't my beliefs right now that are
regulating my emotion.
It's the fact that I'm acting out those
beliefs which include implicit
perceptions.
I'm acting them out.
And so are you.
And so what you're doing and what I
expect more,
more accurately,
what you're doing and what I want you to
do and the way I want you to react.
To me,
that's working.
So it's the match between my belief
system and the way everyone else is
acting that's regulating my emotions.
It's not the belief system.
It's mediated by the social culture.
And you see,
if you understand this,
then you understand more particularly
why people are willing to fight to the
bitter end to protect their culture.
It's not a psychological structure that
they're protecting.
It's a psychological structure and a
sociological structures.
Simile,
Tanium [inaudible].
So the social contract is you have a set
of expectations and I have a set of
expectations.
They're actually desires.
They're not merely expectations because
as living creatures,
we're desirous,
we don't just expect.
And so you desired outcome and I desire
and outcome and we agree to act in
accordance with that.
That's the social contract.
And so people don't like to having that
disrupted.
Well it isn't because it's
psychologically destabilizes them.
Although it does.
It's because it actually destabilizes
the right.
If all of a sudden we can't occupy the
same specified domain of territory.
It isn't only that we're thrown into
psychological disarray,
although we will be,
it's that we'll start fighting with each
other like,
and that can kill you.
It's no joke.
It kills people a lot.
Like it happens.
It can happen very easily,
that are cohesive social group can
fragment along some fracture line of
identity let's say.
And all hell breaks loose.
You know,
that's what happened with the Tutsis and
Hutu and in uh,
in,
you know,
and those things can get out of control
just so fast.
It's just unbelievable.
And so,
and that wasn't death anxiety,
that was death.
That's a whole different thing.
And that's the other thing,
the terror management people don't
exactly get,
it's like,
it isn't just that your culture and your
cultural beliefs protect you from
anxiety and say anxiety about death.
Even it's that they actually protect you
from death as well as protecting you
from death.
Anxiety.
I mean,
look,
it's warm in here.
It's cold outside.
The fact that the culture is intact
means that you're not outside freezing.
That's a hell of a lot more fundamental
in some sense than mere anxiety.
Although I'm not trying to underplay the
role of anxiety.
That's a major issue,
but there's something that's a lot more
fundamental at stake than mere
psychology.
So it's the match between your map of
the world and other people's actions
that regulates your emotion.
And,
and it,
it regulates it completely because you
know,
if,
if someone in here started acting
seriously deranged,
like brandish to pistol,
let's say all of a sudden you would not
be in the same place at all,
not a bit.
And so what would happen?
Well,
chaos would happen and chaos isn't just
that you would get anxious.
That's not a good enough explanation.
What would happen is more complex than
that.
What,
what happens in some senses that your
body,
and it does this,
does this,
what would happen is that you would
react the same way that Iraq reacts to a
cat.
It's exactly that.
You would respond as if a terrible
Predator had emerged in your midst.
And so what is that reaction?
Well,
it's not just anxiety because when you
encounter a Predator,
anxiety isn't the only thing that's
useful that just makes you freeze.
It's like that could be the worst thing
you can do.
You freeze and well you're a pretty easy
target so you have to be prepared for a
lot broader range of responses.
The mirror,
mirror,
Petrofac location,
like how bout a little aggression that
might be helpful.
You don't know.
It also might get you killed,
but you know,
maybe you can take the guy down and
maybe that's a good idea,
you know,
and,
and maybe you have to run.
So that's deceive inhibited as well.
And maybe you have to think really
quickly and reflexively.
So that happens.
That's activated disinhibited I would
say as well.
It's like your whole being is thrown
into intense concentration on the moment
and you're burning up physiological
resources like mad.
And so what will happen after something
like that if you don't develop outright
posttraumatic stress disorder,
which some of you would,
is that you assuming that the situation
was brought under control,
you'd walk out of here shaking with your
heart,
rate it like one 70 and it would take
you like,
while it might take you the rest of your
life and maybe you would never recover,
but you could bloody well be sure that
it would take you the rest of the day.
That's for sure.
And so it's no joke when someone steps
steps outside the confines of the social
contract,
right.
And that's kind of,
there's a philosopher named Hobbs who I
suppose in some sense was a centrally
conservative philosopher as opposed to
Russo,
who's kind of his exact opposite.
Rousseau believed that people were
basically good in their natural state.
So he believed nature was basically good
and he believed that culture was what
corrupted people.
And,
and so,
and uh,
uh,
Hobbs,
Thomas Hobbes believed exactly the
opposite.
He believed that in the state of nature,
let's say every person was at every
other person's throat,
and the only thing that prevented
continual chaos was the imposition of a,
of a collective agreement that would be
the social contract that essentially
governed how people would interact and
that would keep that underlying chaos at
at bay.
And you know,
my contention is is that Hobbes was
correct and Russolo was correct.
And I think that if you add Russo and
Hobbes together,
you get a total picture of the world.
And that's really,
I think the picture of the world that
I'm trying to relate to you.
It's both at once.
It's like,
well you can't just attribute human
malevolence and unpredictability to
society.
It's does.
It's a nonstarter.
It's like people build society.
So all you're doing is pushing the
problem back.
It's like where did it come from while
society,
this society before?
Well then the one before that,
it's like,
well you got to tangle up the individual
in there at some point because people
created society.
And so you can't just blame human
irrationality and malevolence on
society.
Well and also it's,
it's ungrateful for God's sake.
It's like society obviously also makes
you peaceful.
Part of the reason you're peaceful right
now,
all of you is because while you're not
that hungry,
you're certainly not starving to death.
You would be a very,
very different person if you were
starving right now.
You know,
or if you were enraged or if you were
panicking or if you were terrified
because your,
your future was radically uncertain.
I mean,
you're just not any of those people
right now.
Europe,
satiated and I mean that technically
you're satisfied.
None of your biological systems except
perhaps curiosity,
which is a rather pleasant emotion are
activated in the least.
And you know,
because of that you all think,
well,
you're in control of yourself.
But don't be thinking that.
That's just not right.
I mean,
if you look at how the brain is
structured,
for example,
the Hypothalamus,
which is a really important part of the
brain.
It basically,
it basically establishes the framework
of reference and the actions,
the framework of reference within which,
and the actions you take in order to
fulfill basic biological needs.
So the hypothalamus makes you thirsty
and the hypothalamus makes you hungry
and it makes you sexually aroused.
If it puts you into a state of defensive
aggression.
And it,
it actually also makes you explore and
be curious.
All of that's hypothalamic.
It's an amazing structure.
And then,
and it's really small and it's right at
the base of the brain.
Um,
and you could imagine it as something
that has tremendously powerful
projections upward throughout the rest
of the brain into the emotional systems
in the cortical systems and all of that,
like tree trunk size connections,
you know,
metaphorically speaking.
And then the cortex has these little
light vine like tendrils going down to
regulate the hypothalamus.
You know,
and if it's,
when push comes to shove,
man,
the Hypothalamus,
that thing wins.
And so,
you know,
you get people now and then who have a
hypothalamic dysfunction and one of them
produces a condition called,
I can't remember it,
it's not dips Romania.
Although it's,
it's like that doesn't matter.
It produces the uncontrollable thirst.
And so what will happen is that people
who have this hypothalamic problem,
we'll drown themselves by drinking
water,
which you can do by the way.
Uh,
and so they just cannot get enough water
and there's no stopping them,
right?
No,
no more than there would be stopping you
if you were suffering from raging
thirst.
It's like,
it's a happy day when the hypothalamus
is not telling you what to do.
And you know,
you live in such a civilized state that
most of the time,
roughly speaking,
you're tranquil and satisfied and more
or less,
you can imagine yourself as a peaceful,
you know,
productive well meaning
entity.
But don't be thinking that that's what
you'd be if you were put in the right
situation,
because that's just not right at all.